were those models and were the
assumptions going into those models
correct if we just take one example Sage
was saying that at the height of coid
you would have 990,000 hospital beds
with ventilators needed I think at the
peak it was closer to 2,500 and almost
half of the ventilators on the NHS
weren't used I want to know rude
comments aside whether or not we think
that it was right to question those
models whether we think enough people
did question those models whether e out
to help out the right trade-offs were
ever considered between the pandemic and
every other aspect of society and public
life and every other illness that people
were suffering from that was keeping
them away from the NHS that was leading
people to lose their jobs and the rest
of it we have not gotten into the
details of that instead the explosive
news stories from the perspective of the
inquiry seem to be who called what when
it makes for good television but I don't
think it's making us any safer for the
future when the next pandemic comes
along